- [Instructor] We are told figure two
is a scaled copy of figure one.
So this is figure two here.
This is figure one.
Looks like figure two not
only has it been scaled down,
it's a smaller version,
but it also looks like it
has been rotated 180 degrees
or you can say it's been
flipped upside down.
We're asked to identify
the side in figure two
that corresponds to side EA in figure one.
So this is EA in figure one.
Pause this video and
see if you can identify
the side of figure two that corresponds
to side EA in figure one.
Alright, now let's work
through this together.
Some of you might immediately intuit
or be able to spot which
side corresponds to EA
but I'll do it slightly more
methodically in this video
just so that we can see maybe all
of the corresponding sides and points.
So one way to think about it
is well, it looks like the
longest side in figure one
is side BC.
So this is the longest side in figure one
and then the longest
side in figure two is HL
so it looks like BC corresponds to HL
and then touching on that longest side,
that longest side has two right angles.
It forms two right angles
with the sides next to it.
So you have these two right
angles right over here
and then of those two right angles,
you have the shorter side
connected to the longest side
and so that is BA over here
and so that would correspond
to LK right over here.
That is the shorter side
connected to the long side
that forms a right angle
and then if we just keep
following that side of the shape,
we then go to side AE which
would correspond now to
and this is answering
our question to side KJ.
So the side in figure two
that corresponds to EA
in figure one, that is going to be KJ
or we could say side JK
and if someone wanted to say
what points correspond to which point,
well, you can see that
BA corresponds to LK
and BC corresponds to LH
so we would know for example
that this point B right over here, point B
would correspond to point L
in figure two right over here
and we could use a similar
logic for the other points.
So we've answered the
questions, the question,
but the real thing is to see
well, which sides or points
have similar features on a relative basis?
So I said what is the longest side?
What is the longest side?
Where do we see right angles?
And sometimes your brain
might just immediately
be able to spot out the shape.
If you were to rotate this
one all the way around,
it would jump out at
you a little bit faster
that JK and AE are corresponding sides.